oh
la pologne un grand pays agricole c'est
là que nous allons nous rendre
aujourd'hui bonjour et bienvenue dans
europe hebdo une émission que nous
allons consacré en partie à la réforme
de la politique agricole commune mais
d'abord l'actualité dominée par la crise
de la dette souveraine
la france et l'allemagne peuvent elles
sauver la zone euro c'est la question de
la semaine
c'est devenu une habitude en europe
avant chaque sommet ils prennent les
décisions à 2 puis imposent leurs vues à
leurs partenaires eux ce sont les
merkozy le commando merkel sarkozy comme
les surnomme leurs détracteurs
il leur reproche de vouloir mettre en
pas l'ensemble de la zone euro
tout a commencé il ya un an à deauville
à l'issue de leur tête à tête
nicolas sarkozy et angela merkel ont
scellé un pacte ils se sont entendus
pour réformer les règles de la zone euro
en vue d'instaurer puis d'harmonisation
en europe sur des marchés de travail la
fiscalité ou encore l'âge de la retraite
un accord conclu dans le dos de leurs
partenaires mais depuis les deux pays
n'ont qu'un mot la convergence
cette convergence franco allemande c'est
beaucoup plus qu'un symbole c'est à mes
yeux une nécessité vitale pour nos deux
nations est pour l'europe toute entière
un pas de deux pas toujours bien
accordés l'allemagne a tardé à venir en
aide à la grèce et si berlin assure
aujourd'hui qu'il ne laissera pas tomber
son partenaire grecque
ces intentions ne sont pas très claires
mais le temps presse pour la grèce alors
paris et berlin peuvent-ils vraiment
sauver la zone euro
et nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par pascal canfin bonjour je
vous êtes député européen du groupe des
verts et membre de la commission des
affaires économiques
ici au parlement européen alors on le
voit la france et l'allemagne entendent
prendre le contrôle des opérations dans
la zone euro est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
en mesure aujourd'hui de sauver la zone
euro
oui le sujet combien de voir laisserait
penser qu'il ya un leadership franco
allemand qui impose ses vues mais le
problème c'est que depuis deux ans
justement il n'y a pas de prise de
décisions qui soient à la hauteur des
enjeux
et donc on n'a même pas de leadership on
a vaguement un couple franco-allemand
qui essayent tant bien que mal de
trouver des choses en commun et ensuite
de les proposer aux autres mais on a pas
de leadership est bon comme on n'a pas
non plus de leadership du côté de la
commission européenne mais a finalement
il n'y a pas de pilote dans l'avion
européen et un avion sans pilote ça
s'écrase c'est un coup de poker à ce que
ce que ce que font l'allemagne et la
france c'est un coup de poker comme le
dit comme l'a dit hier jacques delors
l'ancien président de la commission
européenne
je pense que oui il ya des
considérations de politique nationale
qui entre en jeu du côté français du
côté allemand
mais au delà la question un temps qui
est posée c'est est ce que on veut
garder l'euro si on veut garder l'euro
il faut aller vers un saut fédéral vers
une union économique et politique et
peut-être qu'on n'ira pas tous ensemble
dans cette direction claire l'europe
s'est constitué petit à petit avec un
noyau dur historique puis ça s'est
élargi peut-être qu'on est à un moment
de l'histoire où on doit repartir à 5 à
10 peut-être certainement pas à 27 vers
une intégration plus poussée au sein du
système communautaire mais avec un noyau
dur qui met par exemple en commun les
questions fiscales qui sort de la règle
de l'unanimité parce que la solution
franco allemand de la solution
intergouvernementale c'est toujours
toujours le plus petit dénominateur
commun puisque comme ces de
l'intergouvernemental il ya un droit de
veto pour chaque état alors une fois
c'est la finlande une façon les pays bas
une fois c'est la république tchèque
nous fasse et la slovaquie qui tire vers
le bas en même temps en france
voit que le premier ministre françois
fillon ne cesse de répéter qu'il faut
aller vers plus de convergence notamment
entre la france et l'allemagne notamment
sur les questions fiscales
est ce que la france n'est pas en train
de préparer l'opinion à une convergence
pour l'an prochain vous y croyez à ça
moi je crois que il faut aller dans
cette direction
ce que je constate c'est que plutôt que
d'avoir un raisonnement global sur cette
convergence
françois fillon veut converger quand ça
les arrange et veut pas convergé cons ça
les arrange pas par exemple le modèle de
gouvernance des sociétés allemandes qui
donne une plus grande part de
responsabilité aux salariés aux
syndicats jamais ils en parlent alors
qu'on pourrait très bien imaginer de
dire c'est un aussi un des éléments du
succès allemand donc il faut regarder
l'ensemble du tableau mais effectivement
je pense qu'on va vers en est un choix
historique soit on revient vers des
nationalismes vers des souverainistes
haut et on prend le vraiment le risque
de détricoter le seul acquis communs
c'est à dire l'euro et on se contente
d'une union finalement économique et à
des marchés comme le veulent imagine le
royaume uni ou alors on fait un saut
fédéral est un choix démocratique
on est vraiment à la croisée des chemins
hier nicolas sarkozy a dit sur un ton
très solennel que la crise était sans
précédent qu'elle était très grave
est-ce que effectivement la situation
penser que la situation est grave dans
la zone euro parce que le rond et si la
numéro à ne pas avoir une monnaie unique
avec des économies qui divergent
sans avoir en plus des mécanismes de
redistribution imaginer qu'on soit
uniquement sur la france
on a on aura une monnaie unique par un
franc ça s'appelait le franc à chaque
fois qu'il faut que l'île de france
fassin transferts financiers vers le
limousin donc une région riche en
gisements région pauvre il fallait qu'il
y ait des négociations sans fin pour
savoir combien le contribuable
francilien les robert on voit très bien
que ça ça peut pas fonctionner et l'euro
c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'il ya qu à
chaque fois qu il faut que la finlande
ou l'allemagne fasse un léger transferts
financiers vers la grèce ou le portugal
c'est des négociations sans fin et donc
soit on dit on est dans le même bateau
on est ensemble on a une communauté de
destin et on met en
las les mécanismes redistributifs avec
des mécanismes évidemment fédéraux de
contrôle des budgets puisque à ce moment
là on crée un espace politique commun et
c'est ça le projet qui est devant nous
soit on fait pas ça et on risque
évidemment de sortir de l'ombre
donc ça c'est les réformes à l'intérieur
de la zone euro il ya aussi des choses
des propositions qui ont été faites
depuis le début de cette crise pour
limiter la possibilité que les marchés
ont d'attaquer la zone euro vous même
vous étiez le rapporteur d'un texte
important qui est passé hier soir et qui
vise notamment à interdire la
spéculation sur les cds souverains
explique qu'elle a portée de cet accord
cette semaine c'est
il ya eu cet accord c'est la première
fois que l'union européenne interdit une
entre guillemets innovations financières
vers les marchés ont créé un outil qui
s'appelle les cds qui permet de spéculer
je rentre pas dans le détail cet outil
là ni la notice spéculatifs
il a été utilisé contre la grèce contre
l'espagne contre le portugal contre
l'italie et on a enfin pris la décision
cette semaine grâce quand même très très
largement au combat qu'on a mené ici au
parlement européen d'interdire cette
pratique
c'est la première fois depuis de la
crise et même avant que l'union
européenne interdit une pratique sur les
marchés donc c'est un pas en avant
important c'est un message politique
extrêmement fort puisqu'on sera la
première zone au monde à interdire cette
pratique spéculative sur les
actionnaires sera en vigueur
concrètement quand ce sera en vigueur
pour tous les futurs contrats de cds à
partir du 1er novembre 2011
donc dans quelques semaines merci pascal
canfin d'avoir été notre invité on
poursuit cette émission la crise
les dirigeants au pied du mur sous la
pression des marchés un accord
institutionnel est intervenu en belgique
on en parle dans un instant c'est notre
zapping de la semaine
irish pas de gouvernement pas de
problème pour la belgique
les querelles politiques ont privé le
pays de gouvernement fédéral pendant 15
mois un gouvernement en affaires
courantes avec des pouvoirs limités à
gérer le pays
mais pendant que l'europe a plongé
victime d'une grave crise économique
les belges sont resté inconscient du
chaos qui les entoure est finalement
beaucoup de pays devraient fonctionner
sans gouvernement flamand et wallon qui
tombent d'accord l'événement est
suffisamment rare pour être qualifié
d'historique
il est tard dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi quand les huit partis
francophones et néerlandophones quitte
la table des négociations pour une fois
avec le sourire après deux mois de
débats
ils ont réussi à s'entendre sur les
derniers points d'une réforme des
institutions
une nouvelle belgique est sur les rails
car la crise politique est terminée
c'est ce qu'annonce mardi elio di rupo
pour le chef du parti socialiste
francophone
après dix-huit mois de vide du pouvoir
un accord a été conclu samedi entre les
huit partis traditionnels flamands et
francophones à la clé la formation d'un
gouvernement dont elio di rupo devrait
prendre la terre si on n'avait pas
trouvé un accord sur le plan
institutionnel
c'eût été un drame est peut-être en
quelque sorte la fin de notre pays
nous sommes toujours à bruxelles au
parlement européen en compagnie de
marcel sel bonjour vous êtes auteur
chroniqueur auteur du blog de sel et
vous vous êtes publié secret un portrait
assez virulents de bart de wever alors
expliquez nous exactement ce qui se
passe en belgique
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
la belgique ait sauvé qu'il y aura enfin
un gouvernement
alors on va on aura un gouvernement très
probablement s'est pas encore tout à
fait sûr on a résolu le problème
institutionnel c'est à dire le rapport
entre les deux grandes communautés et
les régions qui sont autonomes et donc
maintenant qu'on a résolu ça on peut
commencer à former un gouvernement de
façon traditionnelle comme on le fait
dans d'autres pays
pcas part importante des mois cet accord
c'est un pas important
alors cet accord et on peut dire que
c'est un pas important du point de vue
de ceux qui l'ont négocié en même temps
c'est un pack qui ne résout pas les
problèmes communautaires
c'est un c'est un accord qui finalement
permet de continuer à avancer un petit
peu mais ça ne résout pas le problème
crucial problème de fond qui est
finalement la question de l'autonomie de
chaque communauté ou de chaque région
c'est à dire entre les flamands les
wallons et les bruxellois ya la question
de bruxelles qui est enclavée en flandre
mais qui n'empêche pas la séance à plat
à comprendre alors oui voilà où il faut
il faut mais vous ne dites que donc pour
l'instant ces problèmes là ne sont pas
résolus ça veut dire en clair qu'on peut
encore attendre des mois et des mois
avant de voir
non non un gouvernement en fin alors
pour un gouvernement l'a en fait c'est
la crise
enfin les problèmes économiques qui ont
fait que certains partis se sont
réveillés notamment les chrétiens
démocrates flamands et on sont rentrés
dans une logique de gouvernement c'est
qu'il y avait en 2005
herman van rompuy d'ailleurs et en 2005
avait dit si la flandre veut obtenir ce
qu'elle veut elle doit refuser d'aller
dans un gouvernement belge
tant qu'elle n'aura pas donc en fait les
francophones les wallons ont négocié
avec le couteau sous la gorge et non ils
ont refusé cette logique jusqu'à il ya
très peu de temps et de son côté les
chrétiens démocrates flamands ont refusé
la logique d'un accord négocié jusqu'à
il ya très peu de temps ci et ben on
voit ce qui se passe il ya dexia est
arrivé je pense que les politiques ont
senti le vent tourner un petit peu
économiquement ou disent menacés de de
rétrograder la belgique téva bon on a un
très grand problème on a trouvé 10
milliards d'euros pour équilibrer le
budget c'est aussi la conséquence de
l'échec de l'accord sur le
saint-françois gouvernement fait
qu'aujourd'hui la belgique se retrouve
dans une situation dont celle inverse
c'est parce qu'il y a c'est parce qu'on
sentait que la situation économique
devenait gravissime gravissime c'est un
grand mot la belgique est un pays assez
riche quand même mais deux que vous avez
un problème à long terme
oui oui c'est finalement c'est quoi le
danger aujourd'hui pour l'avenir de la
belgique est ce que quelqu'un comme bart
de wever wii représente effectivement il
faut savoir très sévère dans votre dans
votre ouvrage vous publiez mais bon gt
gt gt farfouiller là où peu de gens ont
été farfouiller en effet au niveau de la
nature de ce sont partis dont ce sont
les nationalistes flamands
ils représentent aujourd'hui en
intentions de vote dans les sondages
quelque chose comme 35% des votes
néerlandophones et tous les partis
nationalistes flamands ensemble environ
42 43 % donc c'est considérable ça veut
dire que le il n'accepte pas l'accord
qui a été signé au niveau institutionnel
et ça veut dire qu'une force politique
en flandre qui reste extrêmement sorte
et qui peut faire basculer les choses
par exemple aux municipales de l'année
prochaine on se fit grace a en tout cas
prochainement merci beaucoup marcel sel
on va aller cette semaine en pologne
elle rencontre d'agriculteurs qui se
plaignent de recevoir moins d' aide de
l'europe que leurs voisins on retrouvera
françois baudot nez avec patrick le
hyaric pour en parler mais d'abord ce
reportage tourné en colonnes il est
signé ja mandrier regardez la pologne
appartient à l'europe depuis 2004 c'est
aujourd'hui la deuxième économie la plus
dynamique des 27 mai la pologne c'est
aussi la culture de la terre près de 15%
la population active travaillent dans
l'agriculture soit quatre fois plus
qu'en france
là mon exploitation vous voyez c'est à
peu près 650 hectares avec 650 hectares
et plus de 400 vaches on peut dire que
yann est une exception
ici les grandes exploitations sont
plutôt rares seul 1 % dépassent les 100
hectares dans la famille on est dans
l'agriculture de père en fils depuis
plusieurs générations
moi j'ai réalisé que j'avais ça dans mes
gènes alors j'ai décidé d'acheter une
ferme d'état dans les années 90 après
l'expérience communiste les grandes
exploitations disparu le paysage
agricole polonais d'aujourd'hui c'est
surtout des petites fermes
traditionnelles
il faut comprendre que ce genre
d'exploitation là comme la mienne c'est
ce qui est plus dur à gérer
il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens ici qui
veulent s'en occuper il faut à la fois
des financements du savoir faire et il
faut même gérer la comptabilité ce que
je pense des aides européennes c'est
qu'elles doivent dépendre avant tout du
niveau de production et des efforts pour
moderniser l'exploitation alors
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
c'est avant tout des aides sociales
et ça c'est vraiment pas juste
d'autres agriculteurs ont fait le choix
la modernisation
c'est le cas de lech et ses 15 hectares
de cerise et de pommes cadavres et
arnèke salut yanek alors cette récolte
tout se passe bien
tantôt vous voyez ces pommes sont
destinés au marché local et une partie
est exportée vers la russie
avec ses 15 hectares la taille de ce
verger est plus représentatif du paysage
agricole polonais mais leetch et
compétitif il a tout misé sur la
modernisation et à la clé des aides
européennes pour financer ces nouvelles
structures 40% des nouveaux
investissements avec un plafond de 100
mille euros
la modernisation est une nécessité pour
l'agriculture sans elle est bien une
serait impossible de se développer sans
ces conditions de production nous ne
pourrions pas être compétitifs nous
serions condamnés à disparaître
et aujourd'hui la pologne c'est plus de
2 millions 400 mille exploitations
la plupart sont de petite taille c'est
le cas de cédric une ferme pas vraiment
moderne plutôt traditionnel 21 hectares
et 25 vaches et comme de nombreux
polonais il a aussi son petit potager
vous voyez ça c'est grosse citrouille
mais c'est pour notre pas et c'est tout
frais vous voyez comment ils sont elles
sont énormes non à la ga au lancement
rien est destiné à la vente c'est bien
sûr pour sa propre consommation
son exploitation enrique le sait ne sera
pas reprise par ses enfants
son seul combat aujourd'hui c'est de
continuer à en vivre et de pouvoir
compter sur les aides de l'europe
je vais vous dire ce que j'en pense je
voudrais que tous les pays d'europe
soient traités de la même façon avec les
mêmes subventions pour tout le monde
vous savez il ya des rumeurs qui disent
qu'on va couper les aides directes
si ces aides directes disparaissent je
trouve ça inadmissible
enrique le petit agriculteur yann le
grands céréaliers et l'aide qu'ils
misent tout sur son développement
trois visages d'une agriculture
polonaise à plusieurs vitesses
tous devront s'adapter en 2013 l'heure
où les règles de l'apa voilà pour notre
grand reportage en pologne signer signé
cette semaine germain andrieu l'on nous
sommes avec patrick le hyaric bonjour
quand je vous êtes député européen de la
gauche unitaire européenne
vous appartenez la commission de
l'agriculture ici au parlement européen
vous êtes vous-même fils d'agriculteur
de pontivy quand on voit ces
agriculteurs polonais envoie bien ces
trois types je dirais d'exploitation
différentes
est ce que la politique agricole commune
qui est en train d'être réformé la
actuellement est ce que l'un des
objectifs de la politique agricole
commune
ces dames d'harmoniser ce qui aura à la
fin finalement plus qu'un seul type
d'agriculteurs l'harmonisation des
revenus et l'aide aux conditions de
travail ce serait nécessaire mais
malheureusement au delà d'un certain
nombre d'objectifs qu'on peut soutenir
ça n'en prend pas le chemin parce que
tant qu'on n'ira pas vers une
rémunération du travail par des prix de
base au moins pour une certaine quantité
de production on aura toujours les
injustices dont on parle et d'autre part
tant qu'on aura un système d' aide qui
sera à la surface et non pas à l'actif
on aura toujours ces inégalités ses
difficultés
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour que
ça change le le système des deux lui
même aujourd'hui est à la surface
autrement dit plus vous avez de surface
plus vous avez des déliés même des gens
qui ont beaucoup de surfaces qui ne sont
pas agriculteurs par un embryon beaucoup
d'années et qui en est qui ont beaucoup
alors 16 ça la commission veut le
changer et c'est un bien
de même elle veut plafonner commencé à
plafonner les aides ce qui est aussi
positif
le seuil est un peu trop élevé à mon
goût on pourrait la baisser mais tant
que l'aide ne sera pas sur l'actif c'est
à dire dans l'est dans une famille les
membres d'une même famille pour
favoriser l'emploi et le travail on aura
les inégalités qu'on concède qu'il
faudrait selon vous que les aides soient
en relation avec le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent sur l'exploitation par
un des critères un des critères
essentiels il faudrait une
conditionnalité sociale c'est à dire
favorables à l'emploi
évidemment des conditionnalités
écologique dont on commence à parler et
de et de vie territoriale en tenant
compte évidemment des différentes
agriculture peut-être l'agriculture de
montagne et la grande agriculture de
plaine il y a des différences donc il
faut aussi la des conditionnalités qui
sont pour partie prévue mais il faudrait
beaucoup accentué cela il faudrait aller
plus loin alors l'un des agriculteurs de
ce reportage dit il ya des pays où en
fait pour la même exploitation pour la
même production on touche beaucoup plus
d alors c'est vrai parce qu'en france on
sait par exemple entre un agriculteur
français un céréalier français par
exemple un céréalier polonais le rapport
est de 1 à 3 en faveur de l'agriculteur
français
est-ce qu'il faut changer ça oui il faut
changer parce que d'abord l'essentiel
aujourd'hui des crédits publics 80 %
vont aux alentours de 20 à 25 % des
exploitations et donc c'est les plus
gros
ou qui en profitent donc il faut
harmoniser cela il faut beaucoup plus de
justice dans la répartition des aides et
ja avec j'insiste sur cette question une
juste rémunération du travail par les
prix du travail et des investissements
qui sont nécessaires d'ailleurs qui
coûte très cher alors là aujourd'hui il
ya une grande discussion puisque la
commission européenne propose de
réformer la politique agricole commune
avec une entrée en vigueur en 2014
est ce que vous trouvez que les grands
axes de cette réforme sont bons les
défis que soulève le commissaire les
objectifs qu'ils énoncent ne sont pas
mauvais sont plutôt intéressant et c'est
différent de ce que nous avons connu
précédemment
mais après nous restons dans un cadre
qui est celui quand même des
négociations internationales de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
sur les sillons de la réforme de 2003
avec tous les inconvénients qu'elle a
eue contesté par tous les syndicats
agricoles sans exception donc c'est ce
fonds là qu'il aurait fallu changer
qu'il faut changer alors nous avons
plusieurs mois de discussions ne
souhaitons pouvoir le faire
compte tenu du fait c'est qu'on est en
co décision pour la première fois en bas
ce faire c'est parlement conseils et
commissions
alors on va repartir en pologne juste un
instant on fait ça chaque semaine parce
que les personnes que vous avez vues
dans le reportage on deux questions à
vous poser la garder moi j'aimerais bien
que toutes les aides soit égaliser mais
j'ai entendu qu'avec l'arrivée de pays
plus pauvre que la pologne tout risque
de s'arrêter ou est vraiment la vérité
ma question est très simple
est ce que toutes les procédures doivent
être aussi compliqué aussi détaillé
car actuellement le système des aides
européennes est beaucoup trop compliqué
la première question à vous laver un peu
déjà déjà évoqué en ce qui concerne la
deuxième question
un agriculteur français pourrait dire la
même chose finalement exactement le
aujourd'hui code d'abord il ya des
conditions très drastiques on oblige à
des mises aux normes dont certaines sont
certes nécessaires mais d'autres sont
totalement superflu on se demande à quoi
ça sert avec une bureaucratie incroyable
on ne sait pas où on se trouve on appris
ce que la bureaucratie ça sert pas aussi
a tenté d'éviter les abus voire les deux
tiers de la reine d'angleterre
on sait qu'il ya des aéroports par
exemple qui touche la politique agricole
commune
bien sûr mais vous serez vu que
l'expérience montre que ces gens là
continuent de toucher malgré cette
bureaucratie la bureaucratie et les
dérives
voilà donc il faut simplifier tout ça il
faut évidemment des contrôles ça tout ça
est nécessaire mais pas toutes 7,7 pas
part à ce pays qui embarrasse les gens
il faut simplifier beaucoup alors dans
la réforme de la politique agricole
commune est un point très important
c'est le souhait de la commission
européenne de verdir l'agriculture
européenne donc qu'elle soit plus
respectueuse de l'environnement etc
est ce que vous trouvez que bruxelles va
assez loin dans ce domaine il ya des ja
d il ya des efforts qui sont qui sont
faits les bandes
des rivages nécessaire il ya toute une
série de choses qui sont faites mais
franchement on ne peut pas dire d'un
côté qu'on est pour le verdissement et
la défense de la planète
quand on va importer la quasi totalité
de nos protéines qui sont produits comme
ans qui sont produits en détruisant la
forêt amazonienne pour une pour une
bonne partie qui sont produits à partir
d'organismes génétiquement modifiés de
même pour le manioc avec des coûts de
transport énorme donc si nous parlons de
ce sujet ce n'est pas tellement telle ou
telle exploitation évidemment il ya des
efforts qui doivent être faits mais ceci
est marginal par rapport aux grands
enjeux auxquels on est confrontés
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous exportons
en quelque sorte nos pollutions vers
d'autres pays henri importants et en
nous mettant nous mêmes en difficulté
puisque nos d'une part de ceux dépendant
nous payons cher et nous ne refusons
toujours il n'est pas de jour du tout
prévu de plan protéines aujourd'hui très
bien merci beaucoup
patrick le hyaric d'avoir répondu à nos
questions c'est la fin d'europe hebdo on
se retrouve avec kathia gilder ce sera
la semaine prochaine d'ici là bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires